huh
I don't have anything
huh you go
you go a suspect is shot and killed
after back to back officer-involved
shootings the first one involving a cop
that was off duty
at about 11 20 a.m on August 24th an
off-duty officer from North Hollywood
was in Bakersfield about two hours north
of Los Angeles the officer called 9-1-1
when he noticed a potential burglary
suspect loitering in a neighborhood
is that where he currently is inside
security video shows the suspect's 29
year old Jason Bowles approach a home in
the neighborhood
is Jason Bowles sorry
next Bulls is caught on camera grabbing
a sweatshirt and gun from a trash can
the next moments are caught on 9-1-1 and
security camera recordings
simultaneously as Bulls approaches the
off-duty cop with a gun in hand
Dr house is currently inside her
okay I need you to tell me what's going
on
I don't have anything
huh
you go
you go after that shots are fired the
off-duty officer drives off then Bulls
can be seen pointing the gun in his
Direction
all right
I'm not going inside the house as the
off-duty officer leaves the area
Bakersfield Police Officers arrive on
the scene that's when a second
officer-involved shooting takes place
Bulls was injured in that second
shooting and later pronounced dead on
the scene a Bakersfield Police Officer
was also shot and injured but was
treated and is expected to be okay right
now the incident is still under
investigation by both the Los Angeles
Police Department and the Bakersfield
Police Department reporting for low on
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie